in relation to
the omicron variant specifically as of 5
pm yesterday there were 696 confirmed
cases in scotland however these are
cases confirmed through genomic
sequencing and this measure therefore
very significantly underestimates the
true volume of omicron cases as i have
set out before an earlier indicator of
whether or not a case is omicron and a
better measure of the overall volume of
cases is the absence in pcr results of a
specific genetic characteristic known as
the s gene
around 95 of all tests that are done in
scotland are analyzed in a way that
allows us to see if this s gene is
present or not
and this has revealed over the past
couple of weeks that omicron cases have
been rising exponentially indeed faster
than anything experienced previously in
the pandemic and as you've heard me say
in recent days cases have been doubling
every two to three days
now last friday when i stood here i
reported that the s gene indicator it
was telling us then that 15.5
of all cases were likely to be the
omicron variant today it is
51.4 percent so that does mean omicron
has now replaced delta as the dominant
covert strain circulating in scotland
and that presents a challenge because we
know omicron is significantly more
transmissible than delta it has an r
number that is possibly above four and
therefore it is driving and the bigger
the proportion of cases that omicron the
more it will drive or the more it risks
driving a much steeper increase in cases
overall
indeed cases have already increased in
the past week by more than 40 percent
and we should expect to see that
continue and indeed accelerate in the
period ahead the tsunami i warned about
a week ago is now starting to hit us
however and this is a key point a really
key point actually we shouldn't be
fatalistic about this we are not
powerless in the face of it and i will
return later to what we can all do now
individually and collectively to slow
down the spread of omicron and try to
avoid these worst fears that we have
right now coming to pass
and slow it down we must because there
is no doubt that as of now the scale and
the immediacy of the challenge it
presents is of profound concern
even if it did turn out to be generally
a little bit less severe for most people
and i want to stress again we still
don't know that to be true
for some people even if that was true it
will still cause serious illness and
hospitalization and tragically more
people will die
and even if the number of people falling
seriously ill is a smaller percentage of
cases than with delta the basic fact of
arithmetic is inescapable a smaller
percentage of a much bigger number of
infections will result in a massive
number of cases needing hospital care
indeed total hospital admissions in
scotland in the week up to the 13th of
december it was slightly higher than in
the week previous so we're already
starting to see an increase as a result
of the relatively moderate rising cases
seen in previous weeks
perhaps more significantly in london
right now where the number of omicron
cases is currently the highest in the uk
hospital admissions are now rising quite
sharply
if we don't act now what we have feared
all along since the very start of this
pandemic but so far managed to avoid the
overwhelming of the nhs could happen um
and that is one not the only but it is
one very important reason why slowing
this down matters so much
but it is also important to understand
that this is not simply an issue for the
health service at the numbers of people
becoming infected even mildly and having
to isolate is already putting a
significant strain on the economy and on
other critical services as people become
infected we lose drivers for trains we
lose teachers for classrooms we lose
nurses for hospital wards and workers
for businesses the length and breadth of
the country so there really isn't a
choice to be made there never has been
but right now there certainly is not a
choice to be made between slowing the
spread of omicron and protecting the
economy we will actually only protect
the economy if we slow the spread of the
virus and reduce the number of people
getting infected with it
that said i realize i am acutely aware
that the steps we're asking people to
take just now particularly that advice
to limit social contacts is having a
severe economic impact
this is particularly hard on sectors
like hospitality and culture these have
been badly affected by previous waves of
covert and the restrictions we've all
been living with and of course these
sectors were hoping until recently with
some justified optimism for a much
better christmas period ahead
so what has happened in the past three
weeks has been a cruel blow to everybody
but it has really hit these sectors very
hard all over again
that's why we in the scottish government
have found 100 million pounds to help
businesses in these sectors i can
confirm today that 66 million of this
will go to the hospitality sector 8
million will go to the food and drink
supply chain affected by hospitality
cancellations and that includes
wholesalers at 20 million will go to the
culture sector 3 million to the wedding
sector and three million to the worst
affected parts of tourism including
international inbound operators we're
working with councils enterprise
agencies and others to ensure businesses
get this money as soon as possible those
who've received support previously will
be contacted directly
and further details of the funding and
how it will be paid are available on the
find business support website
the support we are providing is
significant but i know it won't fully
compensate these sectors for the impact
they're suffering right now that's why i
wrote to the prime minister yesterday
asking the uk government to provide the
support that is needed
in my view business now needs the type
and scale of financial support available
earlier in the pandemic
and the reality is whether anybody likes
or not that can only come from the uk
government because it has borrowing
powers that the scottish welsh and
northern irish governments simply do not
have
i'll press this point with the prime
minister when i speak to him later today
i had hoped that i would already have
spoken to him by now
because we must all realize that with a
virus doubling every couple of days
businesses already bleeding every 24
hours counts there is no time to waste i
hope the conversation later will be a
positive one and that it will give
businesses the assurance of support that
they so badly need